very
akash
akash rby
okay that's not even close
it's driven by Ban's deal with the
Dodges right basically the 700 million
became the Baseline even though that be
was worth only 450 million the time
value
what happens your price price
playes I mean in let's face it Max freed
is not worth what the Janes are paying
either but set by what other people are
paying okay
folks you ready you ready for the two
questions okay so this this is going to
be the last class as this version of the
question how many of you picked a
company for your
project okay next week I'm going to ask
you how many have not picked and
presumably the numbers are going to
reflect the fact that most of you have
picked a company right so you don't have
to pass the companies by me so basically
go to the master list just you know have
some sense holding these companies
together because give you at least a
common ground we collect data that you
can
share so let's continue our discussion
of where the power lies in a company if
you remember last session I dug a hole
for utopian Corporate Finance right
shareholders have little power over
manager so what do managers do whatever
they
want lenders lend money to a firm they
don't protect themselves they are going
to get ripped off the Nabisco effect
companies might not lie to financial
markets but they clearly try to control
the flow of information to financial
markets they delay in bad news they try
to hold it back and markets are not
Angelic either they react in strange
ways they make
mistakes and companies and businesses
and this is not just about publicly
traded companies or big companies all
businesses create side cost for society
and sometimes side benefits of
society that's the world you and I live
you're saying why would I want to
maximize stock prices in that world okay
you don't want to maximize stock prices
you got to tell me what you're going to
do instead and today I'm going to focus
on three choices you can make one is
that instead of stockholders keeping an
eye on manager which is the system we
just described right the it's up to the
stockholders to get rid of mad
management the traditional corporate
maybe somebody else somebody more
informed and now I'm going to sound a
little elitist because these systems I'm
going to describe are at their core
elitist systems where some people are
viewed as better suited to fix these
problems and others so I'm going to
describe corporate governance systems
that are centered where the power lies
somewhere else somebody else is in
charge of getting rid of bad managers
I'm going to talk about different
metrics you can focus on instead of
stock prices why not Revenue growth why
not earnings
what and third I want to deal with maybe
coming back to maximizing stock
prices but maybe fixing the problems we
just described now I'll give you my bias
up front I'd like you to come in with
the third one you know why because all
of the corporate finance that I know
that's out there was built on the third
objective so we pick a different
objective we've got a problem we've got
25 sessions of this class and I don't
know where to go next I'm going to try
my best but I'm I will not convince all
of you at the end of the session this is
a process I wanted to start thinking
about what the end game for a business
is so let's first start with a question
of what other system could I use you go
back to
1945 end of the second world war the
German and Japanese economies were
non-existent they were completely in
chames and over the next 40 years in
what could be described as true economic
Miracles they built themselves Back
Again by the time you get to the mid 80s
they were the second and third largest
economies in the world and they got
their using a very different corporate
governance system than the
US in Japan you had kyat what are katus
companies holding shares in each
other 100 companies each owning shares
in each other and here's our corporate
governance work if one of the companies
was badly managed the other 99 managers
got together and replace the 100th
manager shareholders were not even part
of the process Germany had a similar
system with a bank in the
middle so DOA Bank might have been the
largest single shareholder in Alliance
Alliance was the largest single
shareholder and semens and they all kept
an eye on each other and it worked
really well for 40 years in fact by the
time you got to the mid 80s there were
people like Michael Porter saying why
shouldn't us companies be more like the
Japanese maybe we need to create our own
version of the Kates because it's
working so
well and then came the 1990s and you saw
the down side of these systems they work
really well at dealing with an errant
manager one company badly run but let's
change the facts let's assume that 60 of
the 100
companies are doing something they
shouldn't be doing systematically wrong
I have a question what do you think is
going to happen the 40 managers who
doing the right thing replace the 60 are
doing the wrong thing or is the reverse
more likely to happen the 60 bad manager
say what's wrong with you guys
why aren't you like
us in the 1990s this took the form of
bad real estate loans at Japanese Banks
let's face it around the world Banks had
made bad real estate loans in the
US they had to take their medicine they
had to go to markets and take their
punishments City and Chase and Bank of
America got beaten up in the early '90s
because they had to take the losses not
because they wanted to but because of
the shareholder pressure they had to
reveal the bad news but they dealt with
it and moved on you know what Japanese
Banks
did they said what bad news they covered
up the bad real estate loans and I think
the Japanese economy paid a price for
the next three decades because
essentially it fested on balance sheets
it affected the Japanese
economy these systems which are top down
systems have a problem there's a
systematic mistake being made by
companies you know what I mean by
systematic a lot of companies are making
the same mistake everybody's Bing too
much
money these systems are not good at
dealing with
them in fact a lot of Asian countries
model themselves after the
Japanese in Korea you had chai bols
which are very much like kyus cross
Holdings and in the mid 1990s Korea had
a debt problem every company was
borrowing too
much but nobody wanted to point out they
were borrowing too much because it was a
systematic problem
so when you think about an alternate
corporate governance system you're going
to say why are we trusting shareholders
the unwashed masses to make these
judgments they don't know much they do
stupid things and I will agree on every
Dimension they might not know much they
might do stupid
things but you're replacing them with a
group that I use the word elit is
deliberately the group of managers why
do we trust them more they went to the
right
Schools they're the smartest people in
the room there's one problem though when
elitists make decisions which is they
have egos and you have egos when you
make a mistake you just refuse to accept
it mean remember the the Vietnam War was
started by some of the smartest people
in the
room by 6768 they knew it wasn't working
but nobody wanted to say we were wrong
they dug the hole it's a problem with
all these systems is that Japan had
a Ministry of Finance were the smartest
people went to
work but when they made mistakes nobody
wanted to say that was a
mistake so in this system though clearly
if you think in terms of corporate
governance you have a system where
managers call the shots shareholders
don't even get hurt it's managerial
corporatism and you're going to run the
company in the best interest of managers
because who you're afraid of
shareholders can't do much to you from
until very recently outside of the
US companies were either run by families
or
managers hostile Acquisitions were
almost unheard of in Europe until this
Century maneral corporatism managers
going to make decisions they're smart
people they might do what's right but
let's face it when their interest and
your interest and you being shareholders
conflict they're going to do the human
thing which is put their interest up in
front
so that's managing but there's an even
worse version that emerges from these
alternate systems which I call crony
corporatism what's crony corporatism at
the center is a Founder a promoter
somebody who started the company might
not even own very many shares but the
entire game is about making that person
wealthier everybody else is a side
player and they co-opt everybody else in
the game all those other stakeholders
are co-opted the bank
has personal connection to the founders
so they get money at lower rates the
government forget about it the
government is essentially a part of the
founders extended
Network much of Asian and Latin America
crony Corp I mean it was publicly traded
companies but sherold has a little power
Founders promoters people who ran the
company we've imported some of that
system to the U us especially in the
technology space right especially in the
last two
years we've put Tech CEOs on a pedestal
and we worship
them in fact I cringe every time I hear
the words founder mode you that's a big
deal now in technology what's founder
mode the founder is going to have his or
her fingers in every
decision-making the implicit message
here is I'm the smartest guy in the room
why would I let somebody else choose my
supply chain for me or pick the supply
book I'll do it I can see the call of
this right I I created this company I'm
really smart why would I trust other
people but the extension of the founder
mode
is it's you can't challenge the founder
founder basically you talked about
Imperial CEOs this is beyond
Imperial so if you decide to go an
alternate corporate governance route
think it out what does it mean what kind
of mistakes are not this isn't a choice
between perfect systems they're all
imperfect the question you got to ask is
which imperfect system creates the least
long-term
risk for for for the economy for
companies for
markets so that's one one route let's
take the second route so let that you
know as I said I I haven't resolved this
you might said there's a better
corporate governance system go searching
for it now but always think through its
weakest legs
it's take the second choice this all
comes because we wanted to maximize
stock prices right in a world where
markets are not efficient What If
instead of maximizing stock prices you
pick something more measurable and
stable like what how about maximizing
revenues maximizing earnings maximizing
earnings growth and God help you if you
call a consultant in because it'll
create an acronym for you to
maximize maximize CFI so what is that
that we'll tell you what it is it's a
great continuing business model because
if you can't measure what they're
maximizing you need them to come in
every 3 months or six months to tell you
whether you're doing the right
thing but you can see the pull of this
right you're saying this markets is
so tough to measure but give me a number
I going focus on it somewhere during the
course of the class I'm going to talk
about this empty idea called Eva
economic value added sounds fancy but
there was a consulting firm called Stern
Stewart founded in New York that for a
while it was the hardest Concept in
corporate
finance it was basically old wine in a
new bottle but the acronym made it look
like it was something new and companies
was say just go maximize Eva
everything's going to be
okay but let's talk about I call these
intermediate
objectives why intermediate maximizing
market share is that a good objective
first what's so good about having a
higher market share
anybody want to help me out it well it's
more than looking good right having
higher market share gives you Market
power and if you have Market power if
you think through it what do monopolies
have 100% market share and then you can
raise prices and get higher margins and
make a lot more money saying that's why
I want to maximize market share I'll
make more
money but if you make that the objective
you sometimes forget about the rest of
the legs
I remember in 1981 American Airlines got
a new CEO his name is Robert
crle I remember the press conference
that he called where he said my
objective at United was is to make I'm
sorry at American is to make it the
number one domestic US
Airline and he succeeded by the late 80s
American was the number one domestic US
Airline in terms of market
share but in 198 there were only two
airlines in the US making money and
neither of them was called
American one was Alaska Air because I
guess nobody else wanted to fly to
Fairbanks and back again at that time
they did a lot of Alaska to the US now
they're all over the place and the other
was a nent Southwest yeah and what did
Southwest do it FW from Dallas to
Houston and back again and and and they
said why aren't you flying the the the
glamour routes right LA to New York they
said we can't make money
the problem is once you put a objective
out there every part of the organization
focuses on it right everybody's focused
on market share they're going to go out
and increase market share who's thinking
about am I making money by doing
this so here's my suggestion many of you
worked at companies we look at their
mission statements there's nothing about
maximizing value it'll be about doubling
our revenues over the next 5 years
increasing our margins
here's what I'd like you to do take any
of those objectives and ask
yourself what's the worst thing I can do
with this
objective because almost inevitably in
the long term it's going to play
out so if you want to focus on a
different objective think it through
what does it mean for the rest of the
decision
making you're saying what about Stak
colder wealth I don't remember when I
heard this term it came out of a law
school which doesn't surprise me because
some of the worst ideas in business come
out of law
schools and know some of your lawers
don't take it personally or take it
personally frankly I don't particularly
care maximize stolder wealth what does
it mean let's keep everybody happy it
sounds so good right all these different
stakeholders and the argument is a
fairness argument which is focusing on
shareholders is so unfair what about
these other
stakeholders let's focus on all of them
you might as well rename this the
Kumbaya objective function
right but let's carry this through and I
want to take it apart because there will
be classes even within Stern where this
will get thrown out casually why not
maximize stakeholder wealth let's see
what that even means right in 2019 the
business round table which is composed
of CEOs of some of the largest companies
us who a statement that I think is the
most Craven statement I've ever seen put
out by a business organization they were
feeling pressure right you're money
making we're going to show where we care
about more so they put out a statement
saying our mission in companies is to
keep everybody happy I won't even list
them out you going to go down the list
we're going to keep employees happy and
we're going to keep customers happy and
we're going to make Society
happy and everybody got up and shared
it's amazing
this has turned business around for
thousands of years people have run
businesses to make money in 2019 the
game has changed has it let's see what
happens when you try to keep everybody
happy all these different stakeholder
groups right are their interests all in
convergence sometimes there are if
things are great then you can hire more
employees pay the more make your
shareholders happier pay your lenders
your customers you can offer special
Services think of the big tech companies
in their Glory Days The Glory Days have
actually faded you could go to the
Google campus I remember going to the
Goog Google campus in 2018 it was a big
play
area slides
and kombucha coming out of TAPS in the
the
wall hundreds of people walking around
say what do they do no I don't
know but when you have a lot of slack in
the system you can do that but the truth
is at some point in time for every
organization these interests are going
to clash and you're the decision maker
you got to tell me who you can't have
this I'm going to keep everybody happy
you got to tell me what the priority of
interest is because otherwise how do you
pick you know why CEOs like stakeholder
wealth
maximization because it gives them a way
of escaping accountability you guys be
shareholders you guys be employees
you guys be
customers and you guys be Society right
so I've had a bad your stock prices are
down 25% you know I come in front of you
say guys I know I didn't do a good job
on stock but it's because I was taking
care of the employees I had to give them
a livable living wage I had to also do
some good things for
society then I go in front of employees
who actually not got an incre a pay
raise in two years and I say you know
what I know you guys are unhappy about
not getting a pair raise but if all
these other the lenders are putting
pressure on me to make interest and we
default if we don't do that the
shareholders are a greedy lot now that
I'm speaking to you and they're out of
the room I can call them a greedy
lot and then I go in front
of let next society and say you know
what I haven't been doing all this good
stuff because I can't afford to this
year you see how and for C customers I
cut back on service I raise your price
saying I can't survive as a company it's
a great escape hatch if you're a CEO
because every group he have another
group to
blame no wonder CEO signed that
statement so here's what I'd like to do
I want to talk about what happens when
you decide to keep everybody happy and
I'm going to give you two institutions
that have done that historically and I
want you to tell me whether you want
every company to look like one of these
two institutions
I grew up in an India where a lot of
companies were government owned
companies and some of you might have
grown up in in similar
settings and if you've ever worked at or
worked with somebody at the government
own company the most difficult thing
about running the company is you had no
idea who you were supposed to keep happy
on any given
day so essentially what your objective
whatever you needed to do to keep the
next group happy is this Legend I'm not
I'm sure it's a true story of a Russian
at that time government own because this
was in communist
Russia where the manager of the factory
was told maximize the number of shoes
you make this
year and it turned out that only the
machine that made left shoes was working
and he maximized the number of shoes
they were all left shoes there were no
right shoes to go with the fact that
nobody could wear these shoes unless
they were one-legged and happen to lose
their right leg was completely
irrelevant you're going to end up with a
lot of waste it's not that government
companies are run by bad people or
inefficient people but if you don't know
where you're going You're essentially
going to make choices that are going to
lead to lots of
waste some of you worked at
nonprofits now I my wife worked with the
this group that helps the homeless in
New Jersey called Bridges and she was in
the board and they asked me to give a
talk to the board so I came in and said
what's your objective they
said to take care of the homeless I said
what does that mean is it to get homes
for the homeless to feed the Homeless to
give and they said it's all of the above
and I said you have limited resources
unless you decide what you're going to
do you're going to end up throwing the
money and and nonprofits do this all the
time because they're willing to nail
this is the objective they spray money
around and the final institution I want
to pick on is the one that we're
standing in right now we are a
university what's a mission for a
university in for speak as an outsider
your University the mission should
be
education so what should be the
stakeholder group that should be put on
top of the hierarchy here
students and especially our biggest
student group is undergraduate students
we've got 40,000 of them paying what
60,000 a year so the hierarchy should be
you know maybe undergrad then graduate
students and then you move down the list
you think that's what the hierarchy
looks like in a university I hate to
tell you this but you're not even in the
hierarchy I sit in on these meetings and
you say what are we trying to do and
they talk about stakeholder groups and I
say where are they in my mission
statement but the problem is without a
state this is why this nonprofit thing
actually becomes an impediment right
they say we a nonprofit don't ask
questions like those there's a pie in
this University and somebody's getting a
slice of the pie and right now on any
given day I have no idea who's getting
the slice you know there are more
administrators now at NYU
than faculty members am I and this is
not just NY this is true pretty much for
every large University how did that
happen when you basically have no
mission
statement this is exactly what's going
to happen so I want you to think about
stakeholder wealth maximization the next
time you hear that in a classroom I want
you to visualize a government-owned
company a nonprofit or a university
which is technically also nonprofit but
a really big bad nonprofit
and ask yourself do I want businesses
run like
that so now I'm going to dump so it's
going this next section is going to piss
off some of you I'm okay with
that a few years ago I did a talk on on
what I call the
Theocratic Tri Factor let me pause right
there what's the essence of a
theocracy like Iran for a long time time
was a theocracy it might still be a
theocracy you're given powers from God
at least you claim and what you say
cannot be challenge because it's not a
political decision it's coming from the
top from that unnamed entity at the top
who cannot be
challenged I call it Theocratic because
the three concepts I'm going to talk
about Brook no push back cuz they're
coming from a position of virtue stay
called to what I mean why would you
argue with it don't you care about
employees don't you care about customers
and of course for a long time it's no
longer true it's ESG for the first 12
years of its existence got no push back
when I wrote about ESG in 2009 now I
feel sorry writing about ESG because
everybody's dumping on it for all the
wrong reasons when I first wrote about
ESC in 2019 I wrote about it because I
was curious how a concept could come out
of nowhere and everybody could buy in
the establishment had bought in who you
know one of the biggest spokesman for
ESU was right Larry Frink who's Larry
Frink Derek you know head of Black
Rock black rock manages $10 trillion of
your money in 2019 he said ESG is good
for Value companies should adopt ESG
because it'll make them more valuable
and my response was
really I but I was curious I said maybe
I'm missing something he's managing 10
trillion of my money maybe he sees
something that I
don't so I started my you know my my my
search of ESG there saying okay there
must be something here I mean everybody
seems to have bought it and the more I
looked the more I was reminded of how
gerud Stein described
Oakland she said there's no there
there which is I don't even know what
that means but basically you dig and say
where is it where is it where is it and
there's nothing
there I'm going to give you the two
Central problems as we go through this
but you got stakeholder what you got ESG
and of course the other concept floating
around and here I might piss some of you
because you might have actually worked
in a job we had sustainability in your
name there's actually an Institute on
the eighth floor of kch within
sustainability on its
name and I was wondered what exactly
does that
mean I'll give you before before we look
at each of these the two Central
problems that you run into with each of
these more with ESC and sustainability
than with stakehold o the first is
they're all pushing goodness right who
Among Us doesn't want
goodness but through
history you've had two paths the good
path or the bad which has always been
easier to be good or to be bad to be bad
that's why we need the Ten Commandments
and we need religion because it was easy
to be good you need none of that stuff
if goodness came naturally you would
need all of that structure so goodness
has always gone with sacrifice if you're
Catholic and lent comes around you're
not told eat whatever you want as much
as you want and have as many milkshakes
is you got to give up something you pick
the thing that you least like to give up
I know that but know you're supposed to
at least in theory sacrifice TT goodness
requires sacrifice and the fundamental
lie that both ESG and sustainability
tell you is they argue the opposite what
did Larry f say you can be
good and you'll be more valuable you can
be good and earn higher
returns you see the Allure of this you
can be good with no sacrifice of course
you're going to choose to be
good so the first thing is it's built on
this premise of of goodness and I'm not
even sure sure how I measure
goodness I'll wage if I went around this
room and I ask you to describe what good
meant to you I'd get very different
answers why because of where you grew up
what religion you are what you know your
the the the culture you have all of
those things are going to feed in so who
are these people at Morning Star sustain
analytics sitting in a room making this
judgment because that's what an ESC
score requires right good bad good bad
so those two things have always troubled
me with these and at at the heart of why
each of them will fail ESG might already
have failed sustainability is on its way
there are those two lies so let's
start now stakeholder wealth
maximization already took about let's
let's talk about
sustainability anybody in this room
who's worked in sustain trust me I won't
jump down your throat I'm just curious
right sustainability So when you say
sustainability I can think of three
versions of sustainability there's
Planet
sustainability we all want that because
we have only one planet to live on it's
always been around and you know going
back in time NGS and others have pushed
for it Green Peace Planet sustainability
then there is product
sustainability this morning I had to
switch the blade in my Gillette
razor I do every 2 weeks it's the most
expensive part of having the razor the
razor itself I got
free product sustainabil presumably
means I'll never have to switch the
razor again hope file the thought away
because there's a third version of
sustainab that's truly scary which is
Corporate sustainability what does that
mean by doing this you will live
forever the Pharaohs in Egypt I think
heard this from their advisors and what
were they told to do when you die we'll
wrap you in bandages stick you in a
crypt with all your favorite things and
you will be alive for the rest of
Eternity only problem is they died
anyway 2,000 years later a British
Explorer broke into the Crypt and stole
all that neat
stuff you're creating a corporate
Mommy so when people say sustainabil I'm
going to put you on the spot are you
talking about you know Planet
sustainability corporate sustainability
or product sustainability and the reason
I think you need to pick is can the two
be at odds with each other if Gillette
created a razor blade that lasted
forever the company is pretty much
done so if you're going to pick the tell
me what you care about at least then we
can have a honest conversation so about
3 years
ago this at the peak of everything being
online I get a call and some you know
person I've never heard of said says can
you give a talk to 50 csos and I said
what's a CSO I'm I I'll admit most of
the acronyms I hear I have no idea what
they are I've discovered that the best
thing to do is rather than act like you
know it is I have no idea what you're
talking about what's the CSO you know
what a CSO is a corporate sustainability
officer I said
really why are you talking to me he said
oh no the 50 so I said okay I'll do it
because I was a little bored that week
and I wanted something to do
so they show up on a zoom call and I
said I have a
question I heard your title what do you
guys
do so I go around the 50 and they give
different answers and it's clear that
they don't even agree with each other
what they're doing so the end of the
call I decide to create my own
classification of
csos so here is the vision of this
incredibly wise CSO so I'm going to is
my fa favorite Star Wars
character when you have a question in
the Star Wars universe who do you go ask
you ask
Yoda a CSO as a Yoda they're so wise
they can see what's coming 10 years from
now so when you make decisions they can
can't do that CU in 2037 it'll catch up
with you I'd love to have y as a CSO but
I'm not sure how you train to be a y CSO
clearly can't come from going to
business school right maybe you spend a
decade up in the Himalayas in a cave
doing yoga and and doing
meditation I can't even imagine somebody
being trained to be a Yoda CSO let's
move down the list there's a Jiminy
Cricket CSO you guys seen the movie
Pinocchio if you haven't you've read the
book remember Jiminy
Cricket R do you know what Jiminy
Cricket did
anybody seems Pinocchio can help
me he stood on the shoulder of Pinocchio
and he was a conscience and most of the
time what did pinio do ignore him and do
bad things he end you know you know I
Told You
So jimy Cricket CS so that they're
corporate consciences so they wag their
fingers that's going to get you in
trouble that's terrible the company does
it
anyway I'm not sure what's accomplished
here other than having a conscience that
you ignore all the
time the third
is came to me while I was watching
madman the TV show that's a great show
about advertising everything is public
relations these
csos are masters of public relations
they can take whatever you do you could
do the most you could be the mob the CSO
for the mob will make what you do sound
good we're keeping population under
control this is good for the universe
right they basically can take whatever
you do you could be a tobacco company a
gambling company and they can frame and
there were a few csos in that room said
how do you look in the mirror and tell
me that what you do is going to make the
world a better
place you've heard of Unilever right
it's old company and for a decade was
run by a mad man I
think because he was fully into the
sustainability story so he told every
Unilever division that they had to come
up with a sustainability statement you
know what unil
makes a lot of food with a lot of
additives in it including mayonnaise so
he told and mayonnaise is one of the big
sellers can you imagine being the head
of the Mayo division you've hired a CSO
for mayonnaise what's his job to tell
the world that they cannot live without
mayonnaise that this is what's going to
make I know this is an amazing exercise
in being
creative but this is not advancing
Planet sustainability in any way I'm not
even sure it's advancing product it's
just making things you already do look
good and there's a final group of csos
who said our objective is to make a
company live forever is that a good idea
company's a legal entity if the reason
for your existence is gone you should
probably leave do you guys want the East
India Company still around I mean this
is a company they made an entire country
a
subsidiary it's kind of a terrifying
thought bring it back let's make
countries into
subsidiaries if your time for living is
done now that's why I both wrote the a
corporate life it's okay to get old it's
okay to go
away so if you're in the sustainability
space I'm not going to talk you out of
the space but I want you to think
through what ex what version of
sustainability you're talking about and
how you plan to use this to essentially
make your company do better
things which brings me to
ESG I have a four level attack on ESG
and I'm going to go right to it first is
this notion that you can measure ESG you
say but there are services that do
that that's a myth there sustain
analytics can do it SNP can do it retive
can do it so the first methology it's
measurable second is that it's good for
Value that's a Larry f story that if you
do good for a while NYU had this little
you know thing running on the on the TV
up front you can be good and you can be
more valuable I had to hide my eyes as I
walk
through are there some companies where
this is going to be true maybe but they
you using as marketing right I'm being
being good because I want to now already
saying what about Patagonia we'll come
back and talk about the pagonas of the
world but this notion that you can be
good and more valuable Cuts against the
grain of what goodness usually requires
that you have to give up
something for a while the biggest sales
pitch for for ESG was if you invest in
company High ESG you'll make higher
returns an alpha
argument this is nothing to do with
goodness you're buying it because you
want to earn a higher return
and finally even if the first three
arguments fail you say but it's making
the world a better place I think each of
those statements is a lie and here's why
first if you look at the services that
measur see there are five or six major
Services take a look pick a company any
company you want take British Petroleum
perfect example right Oil Company fossil
fuel company retive gives it an
incredibly High ESG score
95 Su stain analytics gives it a much
lower ESG score they don't agree So you
you're saying isn't that always true you
take Bond ratings S&P Moody they're
incredibly highly correlated for the
most part a AAA rated or a double a
rated company is not going to be a
Triple C rated company but with ESG
ratings and why should that surprise you
what do we say about goodness that group
in each room is deciding so if your
focus is climate change BP has no way of
climbing to the Top If your focus is
something else in that ESG
ladder you could pick BPS one of your
most noble companies out there so this
notion that it's
measurable you know what the what the
fallbacks I gave the stock at sustain
analytics they said this this problem
will go away I said why because the EU
is coming up with a measure of what's
good looking to the EU for good business
ideas is like asking a vegan where to
stake this is not a good idea the wrong
place to look so the you is going to
come up with this know they use a word
and I something to taxonomy I remember
first year what's a taxonomy set it
turns out 500 pages of do this do this
do
this just because the EU says this is
good doesn't mean you've come to you
just have let somebody else make that
convergence for you the second this
notion that es increases value
is
nonsense it's nonsense because I live in
this space for something to affect value
it's got to show up either in the cash
flows or in the risk so actually when I
first looked at es I took each number
and said is is you know is being good on
ESG going to incre so let's take Revenue
growth is being a high ESG or a good
company going to let you grow faster I
actually think it's going to do the
opposite I use the example of Patagonia
what is Patagonia
do make really I think $500 codes for
Guilt Rd in Millennials who say look I'm
wearing a
Patagonia I'm making the world a better
place but it is a company that lives
around goodness right you read the
annual report it's 95 pages of look how
good we are and I actually admire pag
because they stay true to what they
do but for those of you Patagonia as an
example of ESG working do you know how
much revenue Patagonia had
in
2024 about a billion dollars in revenues
it's a niche company serving a niche
market and it can focus on ESG and being
good because that niche market actually
likes that do you think Nike with 40
billion in Revenue can afford to be
virtuous I mean if Nike said I don't
like what's happening in China we're
going to pull out of China it's not
going to work right so the first thing
is when you think about being good it
comes with a
cap the oldest business in the world was
a was a business called congi it's a
Japanese
business that was around for 1,500
years you know what it did maintain and
build Japanese shes and that's all they
did it was a small family-owned business
that's all they did and they stayed
doing it so they could afford to stay
true to their culture to their beliefs
because they weren't Ambi the minute you
bring ambition into the room it's going
to challenge do you want I mean Etsy
faced this in a very very explicit way
you're familiar with Etsy right it was
started as essentially a business to
help craftsmen who couldn't get on to
stores or and was started as a for
benefit corporation which means that you
don't have to keep shareholders up and
up you can keep and then they ran into
problem at about 2 billion in revenues
they realized that being a you know uh a
company that served was not going to
allow them to do because let's face it
they face a fundamental challenge right
they've got to decide which group to
exploit is it the Craftsmen or is it the
customers and they said we're tired of
dancing the dance of saying we don't
care we do because of all these people
to pay they switch to become a regular
company so if you want to be good except
it'll come with a cap on growth you'll
be a niche company and you have to be
okay with it second I looked at profit
margins are they higher
for high ESG companies and low ESG
companies and at first side they looked
higher I call ESC The Accidental
Tourist the reason I call The Accidental
tour is at least in the early years of
ESG guess what kinds of companies were
at the top of the RS because highly
carbon footprint based tech companies
had really high ESG scores and what kind
of mod margins do tech companies have
really high margins this had nothing to
do with the seu you are picking software
companies as good companies because they
have a carbon footprint and claiming
that their High margins were because of
ESG in fact if you think of any given
company and saying I want to be good
what does that mean your next Factory
has to be built in a place where you
know people might be paid a living wage
you can't break the rules and I'm I'm on
board with that but don't tell me doing
that is going to reduce your cost it has
to increase your
cost and I have to be okay with it as a
shareholder the reinvestment will skip
because I can't even think of a way but
being good at ESG is going to mean your
factory is going to cost you less money
it might cost you more so your cash
flows are actually more likely to be
lower than higher if you decide to be a
good company you saying what about
risk do any of you have a CFA
okay about five years ago the CFA did
this absolutely
feckless thing which is there a version
of the CFA called for for ESG
certification try it it's 100 multiple
choice questions that you can take with
no so they did it why because they
thought they could make
money and I I remember saying you know I
would I don't have a CFA after my name
because I've never wanted one but if I
had one this might be the day i' remove
it and it's actually easy to do just
stop paying them and you can remove the
CFA and one of the multiple choice
questions they had was having a high
score will give you a lower cost of
capital true or
false what do you think the answer they
wanted to give you
giveway true having a higher ESG score
week and I remember somebody emailing me
say is this
true I said let's test it out it's a
it's it's an empirical question so I
went to refinitiv which is one of the
services and measures ESG and they also
have an estimate of cost of capital so
this way I couldn't be accused of making
up my own cost of capital I took their
ESC scores and their cost of capital and
I created a table where I classified
companies based on ESG scores refini of
ASC scores and cost First side it looked
like the CF was right higher ESG score
companies had lower cost of capital and
you think this is good the CFA is on to
something but you know that ESG scores
are skewed upwards for larger companies
the larger companies get higher ESG
scores in smaller companies why do you
think that
is I mean do you think larger companies
are actually nobler than smaller
companies so what do you think about
this process is giving you you know if
you get a chance right to Morning Star
they might actually send you the
document the sustain analytics document
that a company has to fill out they ask
you for it's like 150 pages of
information they need from you you need
three people working full-time to just
fill this document out if you Google
with all those hundreds of people
walking around the campus give them one
of the you know pick five of them maybe
make six because they don't work as hard
you know let six of the but if you're a
small business what is the time to do
this so ESG is cute to so here's what I
did I classified companies based on
market cap from large to small and the
entire ESG effect
disappeared ESG High ESG companies look
like they have lower cost of capital
because they happened to pick larger
companies
yeah there is this V this this thing
called a green Bond and people willing
to lend money at a lower rate basically
it requires people lend money at rates
lower than they should be charging
because you're a good company and there
is this group of investors called impact
investors who willing to accept that the
only problem is secretly they all want
to make money too so much as they give
you lip service as to doing this I
haven't seen a single company other than
green energy companies where you can
actually live on subsidies in the green
bonds where green bonds actually and to
show you how much of
a how much hypocrisy there are on green
bonds three years ago when I valued the
adani group and they were having a
scandal you know the adani group Des
does anybody know what
what you walk into Mumbai
airport it's a a darney project they
built ports and they had green bonds I
said how the heck you give green bonds
to companies that are at the heart of
creating all of the carbon footprint We
complain about right what's flying out
at the airports not Birds
and I said if the adani group crashes
there'll be one group that I will cheer
for losing all their money it's a green
Bond holders right because in a sense
this is you know if you re so it is true
there is this small opening where if you
can access debt at below market rate
your cost of capital might be lower but
it's not enough to show up in the larest
scheme I'll give you the one place where
I'm willing to concede that it's not
even being good just don't be
bad if you cross the line and you're bad
there is a risk that your entire
business could be at
risk I'll give you an example company
called Valiant Canadian farmer
company Rose from nothing to become a
hundred billion company now what is
basic business model
was it bought drugs that were old
already patented and in use for treating
diseases that affected a small subset of
people so so typical patent runs 17
years so a drug is six years in the
patent already they'd buy the drug and
right after they bought the drug guess
what they did to the price of the
drug they quadrupled it now I tell
businesses if you have a story for your
business that you cannot share with your
elderly aunt or mother you have a
problem imagine a Thanksgiving say what
do you do I work at valian what does
valian do well we buy these drugs that
people need to live and we quadruple the
price you're not going to be sitting at
the Thanksgiving table for much longer
right even your elderly answerers I
don't want to sit next to this guy he's
Satan but Valiant
succeeded but it succeeded so well that
it became a big company and you see why
this becomes a problem right because the
next drug you buy has to be a little
reach more people and people
noticed and then the whole company
unraveled because when people noticed
they said I don't want to work at this
company they lost all their science in
the Rd Department know nobody wanted to
have contracts with them in fact it got
so bad the company lost about 90% of its
market cap it's never quite recovered
but it actually had Chang its
name I remember when when somebody asked
me if Facebook changed it name to matter
I said there are usually two reasons you
change your name one
is that the old name carries messages
you don't want to carry and the other is
you want to go in the witness protection
program this was the witness protection
program version of it saying I want to
run they're now called ban la which was
one of their
divisions so don't be
bad I agree being bad increases failure
risk but it's very difficult to see
where the value factors you're saying
what about the alpha well there's
actually if you look at the alphas at
first side again it looks like high ESG
companies at least for the last decade
had high Alphas but I gave away the
reason why right they in they put
technology companies was a tech decade
of technology and then Along Came
2022 and the whole DSG Alpha story fell
apart because Russia invaded Ukraine and
all of a sudden the worst companies in
the ESC space the the old fossil fuel
companies sold in price and ESC was
faced with a moment where they couldn't
walk back this was never about creating
Alpha it was an accidental
Alpha you know what if ESG had been sold
honestly from the front which is we want
companies to be good it'll cost you go
get your shareholders
on I think it would have been a much
healthier version of ESG that survive
the ES she that made it through this
process was complete fiction and you
can't walk it back because you have a
fiduciary problem because if ESG
actually costs you returns and you've
been investing based on ESG and you're a
pension fund or you're an endowment you
got a problem that you cannot just
explain away that you might end up in
court and finally saying but this is
good for society I have a challenge for
you and anybody who's in the ESU
sustainab space is welcome to take me up
on this name me one problem ESG was born
in 2007 or 8 name me one problem that
ESG targeted in 2008 where we're better
off
today we've moved in the right direction
on that
problem than we were 16 years ago saying
what about fossil fuels what percentage
of our energy did we get from fossil
fuels in
2008 but 83% you know what percentage of
energy we get from fossil fuels today
about
83% it's barely Bud she's saying but
what about all the stuff I hear about
solar power and you know Hydro power
it's true they've doubled from like 4 to
8% see why isn't it showing up because
there is another source of energy that
we've systematically made a smaller
piece of the pie right which is remember
that that team in the room saying this
is good this is bad for the longest time
when they got to energy they said solar
power good
Hydro power good wind power good fossil
fuels bad nuclear power which pile did
it go in
bad what we've
gained now if your endgame in ESG is to
sound good we all there right we all
sound better you know annual reports
read so much but if your end game has
actually changed the word where is the
beef where's the impact in fact that was
the title of my I'll send you the piece
of impact investing where's the impact
in Impact
investing so this seems to me almost
like you're just running in place and if
you ask ESG people they come up with all
kinds of justifications one is they said
the way ESC has been measured is not the
way I would measure it if we did this
the right way all have work which
reminds me a little bit of what you
heard about socialism in the last
century you'd ask any socialist know why
isn't social it's because the right
version of this is no way to defend a
concept by saying if I if you use mine
because the way it's played out is the
way it's played out they complain about
green washing you know what green
washing
is companies making it look like they're
doing is that green washing hell of a
lot but it's a feature not a bug of an
ESG system the minute you score
companies and give them an ESC score and
people learn the score in
system you know what they're going to do
right they game the system Business
Schools when business school rankings
first show showed up in 1982 it changed
the way Business Schools behave you know
now every top business school accepts
people that they know will you know when
they look at acceptance rates because it
affects their ranking that affects who
they let it so you could be a really
well you might want to come to stern but
they look at their qualification say
this person's probably going to Harvard
or Standford they're not picking Stern
over they'll reject you not because your
packet is not good enough but it makes
their admission rate look
worse what the minute you start scoring
s something you're going to create
gaming around it and the more you try to
fix it guess what you do you make the
gaming go to a different level green
washing is not a problem that's going to
go away it's only going to get
worse and you are in a sense as investor
customers we're all Outsourcing goodness
right we want the world to be a better
place but we don't want incon I mean
let's face it the the finger should be
pointing back at all of us we all want
to make the world a better place but we
really don't want to inconvenience
ourselves too much in the process we
still want that ventti cappuccino from
Starbucks in that cup which is not quite
degradable what you say it's okay and
you have this big SUV that you really
don't need you're one person you weigh
120 pounds why the heck are you have a
Land Rover SUV it's okay it's just me
but you know how you fix it at the end
of the day you go back home and you buy
an ESG
fund we've allowed people in a sense an
escape hatch for their
conscience
okay and behind the curtain there's an
entire ecosystem that's been built
around these Concepts
now remember in in I think in law
schools there's whole idea of kuon or
who benefits there's an entire ecosystem
measuring Services Consultants Bankers
all pushing I mean to give you an
example go back to Black Rock black rock
created what was called a climate
sustainability fund TR admit it that
sounds good right somebody actually went
through the work of comparing the stocks
in the climate sustainabil fund to one
of the regular
ETFs the regular ETF at 500 stocks the
climate sustainability found at 497 out
of the
500 and the only difference was the fees
on the climate sustainable fund were
three times higher than the ETF come on
yeah you're Larry think you talk about
ESG I'm saying this is the hypocrisy
here that's why I said this is a concept
Bor in
santimon I agree we all want to make the
world a better place go join a religious
order try to convert people go work for
a nonprofit I would have know nurtured
with hypocrisy I get invited to talk at
ESG conferences don't ask me why I never
physically show
up I do it online because it gives me a
chance to ask the question right they
didn't invite me to Baku AER Bajan it's
not an es conference but it's very
similar
group first question I would ask is how
did you guys get tobaku
what parts of the world did you you
probably created more carbon footprint
getting to Baku than anything you do
here will do in terms of reducing a car
hypocrisy in the space is just
mindboggling there are very few things
in the world that I see is black and
white on this one I'm there and so when
you say ESG my question is are you
useful idiot or a factless name I'm
trying to put you into the right spot
right group right useful idiots
basically say I'm doing good for the
world and feckless Naes no they're not
Larry think definitely feckless name
yes
yeah but that was only the Side Story
the hypocrisy makes me hate the people
right the underlying problem with the is
nothing to do with hypocrisy right the
fact that you yeah
about is this something that's happen is
this worry we have about social cost
something that's been around only the
last 20 years it's always been around
right it's business and whose
responsibility was it to kind of put an
order where you didn't create too much
Social cost
no but don't say right who know
historically who where did we put that
responsibility that you know government
laws Regulators I'll tell you what 2008
did to us that I don't think we we we we
will ever recover from it ruined our
trust in
institutions right what used to be
something that we needed govern and I
think that's the problem of thec it's
taking what should be our responsibility
and and passing it on to corporate CEOs
this is not going to end well from that
perspective
yeah
and right and I think that's perfect I'm
okay if you have rules that affect
everybody I can live with the problem of
the is you're asking people to do it
voluntarily and some people will and
other PE we we're actually turning the
world over to the worst Among Us right
because in a sense the good companies
would say we're going to follow these
guard rails and I'll give you a story we
put pressure on fossil fuel companies
I'll come back to you okay and I don't
know whether you remember this famous
Victory won by this activist fund called
engine one at Exxon Mobile so about six
years ago engine one was a small
activist fund at that time they claimed
to be ing fund now now they removed that
from their description
and they put pressure on Exon Mobile and
they won the fight it's a huge headline
the next day the fight was they got Exon
Mobile to divest itself of of at least
some of its its worst fossil fuel
reserves the the dirtiest
reserves and I remember people
celebrating this is amazing the word
they miss was
devest what does devest mean it doesn't
go away somebody's buying it right in
the last 15 years you know that price
private Equity
Funds have invested almost $2 trillion
in fossil fuel reserves that they've
bought from companies like Exxon Mobile
and Royal Dutch do you feel better now
that you've turned these reserves over
from companies that you at least had a
chance of controlling it and given it to
carile that's basically what we've done
is we pushed the problem behind the
curtain we put pressure on a subset of
companies and then we wonder why the
problem does doesn't get fixed we should
stop measuring the impact of impact
investing by how much money you
spent and start measuring it by actually
looking at the impact go
ahead y That's
a I've always wondered why there is a g
in ESG right because it does look like a
good thing right because it actually
stole an idea that's been around Finance
which is Corporate governance which we
spent a lot of last class talking about
and put it in the g n ESG has nothing to
do with the corporate governance we
talked about it's got more to do with
stakeholders basically that every
stakeholder group is going to hold
managers accountable he's saying why did
they put put it in there for the same
reason that East Germany before
reunification does anybody remember what
was
called France what was the East Germany
called before reunification do you
remember German Democratic Republic
there was nothing Democratic or Republic
about East Germany but they call
themselves the German Democratic it's or
willan right you call yourself the
opposite of what you are so I think the
G and ESG is a complete distraction it's
there to make it look like they care
about traditional governance I would
just take it out because it's really not
even a serious consideration in terms of
what drives those ESG
scores so I've dumped enough on
ESG I'll let you kind of fester in
whatever I've let let you know and if
you don't agree that's fine that's
that's okay if you want to work in the
Su space try to make it healthier if you
want to work in the sustainabil space
start asking question what do we have to
give up that is the healthy place to
start this discussion not what can we
get from doing
this which brings me to the third I'm
almost by default going back to
maximizing stock price but I'm going to
try to do it and fix some of the issues
we talked about which is what
shareholders of little power we talked
about managers doing what they want is
there something we can do to prevent
Managers from overreaching we talked
about lenders lending money and not
being protected getting ripped off what
can what can we do to counter that we
talked about firms lying to financial
markets so what's in this process that
will keep that from from
exploding and finally we can talk about
social cost and benefit
what is it that we as consumers and
investors what is it that we can
do to kind of make companies behave
better so let's start with what the what
I see as the biggest sales pitch for
staying with maximizing stock
prices it's the only
self-correcting objective I can think of
why because you overreach on any of
these Dimensions there's a push back
let's take let's take the stockholder
manager conflict which the stockholders
of little power managers put their
interest and initially you take it right
why because you have no choice you sell
your shares you move on but there is a
point where you get pissed off enough as
a
shareholder I don't know whether you've
ever seen this movie network where this
guy who's a news announcer finally loses
it and he has
a I basically I I've taken as much as I
can and I'm going to fight back you're
saying how am I going to fight back as a
small stock you look for a vehicle
for your anger we're going to talk about
activist
investors car like can the these are not
nice
people I don't even know them so I
shouldn't say that but they don't seem
like ni I don't want to go to dinner
with Carl I can I I'm afraid he' eat
me but I call them the laxatives that
markets need because they're there to
contest these companies that overreach
we'll talk about why carlan fa know
fails on some companies and wins on
others and the key divid is how pissed
off a shareholders of the
company and an extreme way of getting
people's attention is a hostile
acquisition companies where managers
keep putting their interest eventually
become the targets for hostile
acquisition you see why that plays out
so that's a
first we talked about the Nabisco effect
right which is you bought Bonds in this
highly rated company it went and did
some really crazy things like borrowed
tons more and you were not
protected you know what Bond holders
started doing after the Nabisco Fiasco
they started building in protections
like what after 1986 when this happened
bonds corporate bonds became
increasingly putable what's a putable
bond if there's a leverage bu like that
you can put the bond back to the company
I want my ,000 back go rip off somebody
else too late to protect the Nabisco
Bond holders but Bond markets
evolved and bond holders learned to put
in covenants you can't do this you can't
do this because they learned they'd been
D you lie to financial markets you get
away with for a while eventually the
truth comes out right and when the truth
comes out what happens your stock price
collapses and it stays down right
because you've lost all credibility
nobody trusts you
anymore so that process also has its
push back and if you're a company that
crosses the line like Valiant
this might not be an argument for being
good but it's definitely an argument for
don't walk too close to the line one of
the companies we're doing is Val take a
you know I'll leave you to take a look
at Val's history in the last decade
there have been some things that have
happened at valy you say who was running
this company what were they thinking and
Val as a company has paid a huge huge
cost in terms of credibility and market
cap because of
it I know we're trusting this Pro
process so let's take each of these
process first when stockholders
initially get exploited they basically
sell and move on but one of the signs
that people are getting really pissed
off is when annual meetings become
unruly
Affairs shers get up and they start
challenging managers they know they
might not accomplish much but it still
makes them feel better second they're
also more likely to be people that call
I can can Target cuz the way proxy votes
work is I talked about you throwing your
proxies away when k i can decides to
contest a company an annual meeting here
has what's called a proxy fight so you
will start to get today's day in the old
days it used to be a phone call now you
might get an email saying if you're a
shareholder in Boeing and you're really
pissed off with the way Boeing is being
run who
isn't send your proxies to us we will
vote your proxies and why would you do
it because you're pissed off normally
say that's too much work I'm too lazy
now you're pissed off enough to actually
take those extra five minutes and
finally as I said hostile acquisition
the typical Target company in a hostile
acquisition is not a well-managed
well-run company much as hollyw would
like you to believe that that's the case
the typical Target company tends to be a
company that's badly
managed what way it earns a lower return
than its pure group has done worse for
its shareholders and often the managers
are very little
holding those are the companies said get
targeted so let's let's go back to
Disney right if you remember Disney's
glor years and let's start with a good
part of eisen's tenure in 1986 Disney
was in trouble as a company they were
still living on the W you know on the
whiffs of Walt Disney who died 14 years
earlier they kept trying oh let's do it
again and every animated movie they made
crashed in
B they were in trouble so they decided
hi Michael I was working at paramont
Michael was not interested initially but
they put in some sweeteners they said
you can come we'll give you a big pay
package you can bring in whoever you
want into the company and he said can I
bring my personal
assistant he said sure can I make them
ahead of a division
absolutely and essentially he came in
and he turned the company around in fact
his personal assistant a man called
Jeffrey kenberg
turn the company around and you are the
beneficiaries of that cultural history
right so if you watch Lion King The
Little Mermaid the original versions
that is the Jeffrey C in fact he was so
successful through business school and
he really successful divisional head
what would you do give him more
responsibilities right but that thought
never even crossed eyes in his mind he
went to the board and he said let's get
rid of this
guy now if you are a conscious board
you'd probably push back right but you
saw the board that I that I describ but
even they had questions that why would
you want to get rid of your most
successful divisional head he said I
don't like the guy it's not a usually a
good reason to get rid of a divisional
head but they said okay and they fired
in fact one of them brought the point
which is when you put kenberg in head of
the animated movie division you also
gave him this contract which entitled
him to 5% because this is eisa thinking
he decid he thought that the animated
division was going to crash and burn so
to make kenberg take the job he said you
can get
5% of the net
revenue on all the movies you make while
you can you imagine living on the 5% of
the revenues of The Little Mermaid for
you could know see which alone will pay
for a castle
right and so somebody in the boat said
aren't you worried that know there's a
contract here said Let's ignore it they
fired him kenberg went to court and the
courts went through the process of Mr
Eiser do you sign this contract he said
yes and why AR you refusing to honor the
contract I would like the guy and the
court said I don't think that's a good
reason to violate a contract pay the guy
150 million which he used a seed money
to start a company called DreamWorks
have you ever watch the Shrek
movies there's always a subtext here
where they pick a Disney movie and they
create a perverse version of it
so Sleeping Beauty is an addiction
problem Snow White hangs out with seven
perverts so essentially say what's going
on here that's the history of kenberg
and eisa playing out in the DreamWorks
movies but for a while he was the right
CEO Isa was the right CEO he turned the
company and changed the company but the
longer he stay the bigger his ego got
and he made it his personal play thing
in fact in 199 six he bought ABC at that
time you know ABC was a separate company
and he said amazing things will happen
turned out there was one of the worst
Acquisitions that Disney did it started
the process of people saying maybe this
guy is overreaching and there's no check
on it and over the next eight years
Disney's stock price slid the company
did
badly and remember what I said if you
keep taking advantage of your
shareholders in the good times there
will come a time when they turn on you
in 2004 Comcast actually made a hostile
acquisition bid for Disney it's the most
insulting hostile acquisition bid I've
ever seen in my life normally when you
make a hostile acquisition bid for a
company what do you have to do you take
the market price and you offer a premium
you know what Comcast did they took the
market price and they offered a discount
they said you guys hate ISO so much it
didn't work but it was basically just to
send that message Disney this is how
little we think of you
and it built up in fact in um 2004 there
was a the Disney kept moving its annual
meeting to smaller and smaller and
smaller
venues I think eventually it would been
a venue where fit only one EO would show
up he'd ask himself questions
essentially everybody within Disney knew
that shareholders were not happy so
finally eisa reacted remember that board
of directors he said I'm going to change
it I'm no longer going to be the chair
this isn't something you're doing
because it's the right thing to do but
because you think this will Salve the
anger so he he made the boat smaller he
made it more Outsiders he you know
removed himself from the chair didn't
work because people were so pissed up
and said we want you gone and in in fact
all of the changes he put in the
corporate governance structure the
smaller board people looked at and said
this is too late you've dug your hole
already and in
2008 Bob Iger became
CEO and he was the
anti- Eiser right small legal basically
he said care about shareholders and for
the first few
years in fact if you think about
corporate governance course which I
don't put much weight on but still
Disney rose from the worst entertainment
company to the best in terms of
corporate governance because looked like
he was doing the right thing he looked
at the board of directors
smaller less beholden his you know
iger's personal lawyer was not in the
board that's a good thing I guess
no but here's the problem and in fact in
2011 I talked about him creating this
this succession plan all good right five
years in he's brought the company back
and then I talked about how the
board essentially
ruined this process by stepping and say
we can't live without you in fact
everybody was on board in 2013 or 14 AA
was the most highly regarded CEO because
people said this guy listen to
us people were ready to go there's Tom
Stags was going to be air apparent he
was waiting in the wings and then the
boat stepped in and really screwed it up
they said you got to stay on and he
listened he stayed on and the entire
layer behind below him emptied
out and the rest is they say is history
in February 2019 finally AA left 2020
left I think partly because he didn't
want to wear mask to the company he said
that's not
and he turned it over to Bob Chek and
for a couple of years Chek ran the
company but I go was the power behind
the
throne back 2022 initially when he came
back people were know Delirious they
said this is good iers
back but that glow lasted only a little
while cuz what's the other phenomenon
that happens when people don't like you
activist investors and in the case of um
Disney that started to happen September
of 2022 and Dan L said doesn't look like
you guys know what you're doing anymore
the business has changed has the
entertainment business
changed
absolutely somebody broke it you know
who broke it right Netflix broke the
business for 100 years the way movie
companies work was and Disney was the
master you made the movie you lined up
all these theaters you put them in the
theaters they ran for what 3 months 4
months 6 months and then you initially
you made them into DVDs and videos now
or you sold them on airplanes Netflix
came in and said and Co didn't help
either remember all those movies that
went directly to
streaming they said you guys don't seem
to realize the world has changed under
you so for the last couple of years lobe
and Iger have been and it looks like
aiger for the moment has won the fight
but this is temporary you can see that
he is on
probation that people are waiting and
that's a good thing as a manager the
only problem is he says he's leaving in
20 there is this problem if you're at
Disney Sher say what happens
next and that day in 2015 when the board
convinced Iger to stay was the day that
this process got
started so I'm going to set up and this
going to be the last thing for today
this's is notion of what a great CEO
looks like who feeds in the notion two
entities one is the Harvard Business
School which every year in the Harvard
Business review writes an article about
these are the characteristics of a great
CEO and the other is McKenzie the
handmaiden to Harvard Business in this
we know what makes for a great CEO and
you read that article and you said this
is an absolute lie because you read the
characteristics that is
measured that's Elon Musk no no that's
not him so you go down the list and you
take a see and you see that almost no
CEO that you know actually meets these
characteristics they just made
up so I start started think about what
is it that makes for a great CEO and I
use the structure of a corporate life
cycle to think through it and you can
help me out you're a
startup what's your what's a big mission
you have you got to sell your story you
got to convince people your story is
amazing you want a Visionary let's call
that person Steve the Visionary Big
Dreams can convince people to go along
let's say you sell people in the vision
you've raised capital what's your next
step you've got to compromise on the
vision you know what happens to
Visionaries who are purists they never
convert into business because they can't
accept so you got to have let's call
Paula the pragmatist says Vision okay
but we we can accept
this you pass through that test you have
to actually build a business that's a
lot of perspiration right Supply chains
manufacturing you want Bob the
Builder you build a business you now are
a successful business and you want to
scale up you got to be opportunist IC
find new markets New
Growth very different set of
characteristics and if you become a
mature company it's all about playing
defense everybody's coming after
you and then you're going to decline you
know who you want running your
company Larry the Liquidator remember
other people's money that was Danny
DeVito's name in the movies Larry the
Liquidator is it possible that the same
person can take all these guyses I don't
think so you can have a person who's the
perfect CEO for your company right now
but 3 years from now I look at your
company say you're not the right person
anymore so when you look at life cycles
I think one of the things to think about
is what how does this change happen in
the 20th century you know what caused
the change to happen time took care of
the problem Henry Ford was the perfect
CEO for Ford when was a startup he was a
Visionary but one of the problems with
Visionaries is they are of of an
eccentric so Henry Ford ma made the
automobile into a mass Market product
with the Model T but how many colors did
the model te come in one black he said
who would ever want a car that's not
black that's Ecentric part it's like
Steve Jobs saying who would want to use
a keyboard it has to be a mouse it is
the nature of
eccentrics but by the late 30s Henry
Ford was outliving his
welcome he'd become a little bit of a
Nazi
and that's a problem but you know what
time took care of it he died and the
Next Generation came in time took care
of the problem but the problem and I'll
end with this with the 21st century
company is the life cycle is compressed
we start next session I want to talk
about the sad but true story of Yahoo
rise and fall and how the management
changes got navigated so I'll see you on
Monday e